oui ça a été terrible pour le brésil mon
fils il ya huit ans en perdant cette
finale de coupe du monde on a perdu
notre dignité
je gagnerai la coupe du monde pour le
brésil
je te promets
nico si tu veux être un joueur
professionnel
tu dois pas avoir honte de qui tu es
et il s'appelle laissant godasses
allez recommencer
le reste viendra tout seul
ça te dirait de passer les tests de
sélection pour intégrer l'équipe de
santos là que 15 ans ton fils jamais
quitté bangui
le style jinga marche est probablement
quand tu étais à santos mais il ne
servir à rien au niveau international je
sais pas jouer comme les autres gars
qu'est ce qu'il y a de mal à ne pas
jouer de la même façon que les autres
tu peux nous montrer ce qu'il se passe
quand tu trouve le courage d'accepter
qui tu es
tu n'as peut être que 16 ans tu es
maintenant un porte parole de cette
grande nation
tout le monde vient regarder son jeu
tout bonnement magique
il faut que tu pousses ton équipe à
croire en elle même l'heure est venue
pour pelé est ce qu'on va la gagner
cette finale j'en ai aucune idée
mais on va leur offrir un match de rêve